I swear these perps are so stupid I'd
make a better Criminal than any of them
yeah you would you'd be an evil
mastermind and everyone would call you
the handsome Bandit thank you Charles
and the best part is none of you could
catch me oh come on I'm fairly certain
you would be called no scratch that I'm
100 sure you'd be called oh all right
challenge accepted all right initial
challenge fine I'll issue it for you
what's the most valuable thing in your
office
my medal of valor
you were such a hero all right how about
this I will bet you that by midnight
tonight I can steal the medal of valor
from your office
Captain let me tell you a little story
you remember when I fell through your
ceiling yes that was six hours ago it
was I admit a disastrous failure but it
gave me the idea for Herman the friendly
janitor you met with Herman I commenced
The Perfect Crime
I caught you as Herman
but you didn't catch Rosa come out of
there
as it turns out our friend Rosa is great
at picking locks
does not surprise me no me neither of
course I had to find a way to get her
out of your office without you seeing
her so I created a diversion not
mistimed perfectly timed so she could
Escape unseen what about the pigeons oh
the gray pigeons they were a red herring
thank you their only purpose was to draw
you into the copy room while two members
of my team broke into your locked office
so now I had a way into your office and
an open cabinet
all that was left was for the Royal
babies to steal your keys yes but you
didn't need the keys the cabinet was
already unlocked you needed a way into
the safe and I got it you were so
concerned with getting your keys back
you didn't even notice the sergeant
steal your phone that's right even the
sergeants on my side I then had Charles
dust your screen cover for Prince the
greasiest smudges revealed the four
numbers you used the most the four
numbers in your passcode based on your
Advanced age I assume that you use the
same passcode for everything your phone
your email and of course
you're safe that would be uh their
assumption last Halloween after you won
the bet I went back to my office to do
everyone's paperwork but I did know
paperwork I started to plot my revenge I
began by creating a word cloud but how
could you possibly have known I was
going to try and steal your watch I knew
you were trying to take something
important to me during the year I drew
your attention to my watch
you're eight minutes late you're 14
minutes late you're three minutes early
in Chicago
you annoyed me into stealing it exactly
now you had a Target but you needed a
plan fortunately walked through the door
handcuffed to Diaz scumbag pickpocket is
Jan McCreary you can take anything off
of anyone anything
[Music]
look on your face
priceless I put McCreery into my
employee immediately fast forward to
this morning you commenced your plan
McCrary stole my watch and then replaced
it with a replica and while you
celebrated McCreary put my watch back in
my pocket the watch never left my person
[Music]
foreign
so how'd you pull it off well it all
started when I went to tell Jake how
badly he hurt my feelings and he yelled
at my breasts oh boy I am not going to
come off well in this story nope
remember when you set off the witch hey
Captain hope Flinch which was weird
since his door was closed but not weird
since he actually heard it over a bug he
planted at your desk it was in an old
muffin that you never threw in the trash
that's people threw away garbage how are
we together
anyway I tapped into the buds frequency
so I had ears on Jake I needed to know
what Holt was up to that's where
Hitchcock came in
I masterminded the entire plan you did
one small thing and I had to explain it
to you like 45 times he left a tiny
crack in the blind so I could read the
captain's lips Sharon and your kids will
distract Jake they'll be here at 9 30
sharp my Waffle xylophone on the cheese
man what my lip reading is not Flawless
now that I knew your plan it was simple
to disrupt while Scully gracefully moved
the witch I got into character Holt
triggered the witch which brought Jake
into the room and I threw the crown in
the trash can exactly as I planned then
I sent you all here placed an out of
order sign on the perfectly functional
elevator made you all walk up 31 flights
of stairs and vomit twice actually it
was four times if you count all the
stairwell stuff you thought I was just
holds Lackey and you thought I was just
Jake's girlfriend well I'm my own person
capable of making my own decisions and I
decided to humiliate you both three
weeks ago Captain Holt asked me to order
a plaque that read the ultimate
detective's last genius I did it and I
ordered three copies in a statue of
Tyrese riding a dolphin is that relevant
to my life yes once I had the flags I
manipulated Captain Hull into toothing
Boyle as his partner all it took was six
bottles of dish soap see this is what
happens when Jake tries to wash dishes
by himself it's like he's helpless
without boil yes
he is helpless without Bueno and you
fell for my trap like a greedy little
rat easy yes it was easy and the next
phase of my plan a quote-unquote skating
accident but you knocked out your two
front teeth false teeth fake blood
I lost my Realty
you made sure I didn't remember that it
was minute five of Seven Minutes in
Heaven with Todd Cohen when he bumped
the wall and the bowling ball fell on my
face maybe I just wasn't at that party
I'm so confused I don't know what's
happening right now I'm so confused I
don't know what's happening right now
title your sex tape
shaking I'm definitely gonna cry title
of your sex tape wait is this really
happening is this part of the heist if
this is part of the heist I will dump
you so hard no please hey it's like it's
really happening okay it's not part of
the heist I promise this is
you are I love how beautiful you are I
love your face and I love your butt I
should have written this down first no
no it's okay go on I love how much you
pretend to like die hard I like the
second one you don't have to okay yeah
you're kind and you're funny and you're
the best person I know and
the best detective
also for reals I love your butt I love
yours too gross
Amy Santiago
will you marry me
Jake Peralta I will marry you
I spent the last six months sewing the
seeds of conflict and I am so sick of
Jake saying he's the only two-time
Halloween Heist winner
I can't believe everyone says you're not
helpful during the Halloween Heist just
because they all think your fingers are
too big
[Music]
we'll show them thanks for inviting me
over for dinner boy that's hugging a
real prominent place isn't it not for
long I was manipulated sorry Kevin don't
apologize don't Terry it's his first
Heist he needs to learn keep going well
after I got everyone acting like maniacs
all I had to do was make you feel bad by
knocking myself out the banner
how did you learn my voice command I
didn't have to I sold you
think
but I wanted to unfurl when I say you
all suck absolutely because you're doing
business with you the pleasure was all
mine
ah that's gonna work I spent eighteen
hundred dollars on that thing you did
Amy stop interrupting Terry's doing his
big speech wait how did you know about
Jake's bunny plan you weren't the only
one listening on those therapy of course
the bunny should have glasses I just
can't believe I didn't come up with it
myself oh you know what Betty Rubble
also gives me a boat you guys were
listening in on my therapy it feels like
a real violation Jake this is Rose's
moment yeah man go tell to your fake
therapist she's fake anyway then I
grabbed the gems jumped off the roof
wrote my name in Flames wait why did you
keep delaying the heist couldn't you
have just wanted Halloween oh I did
these are the real Halloween gems I
switched them out before cheddar found
them I also won on Valentine's Day what
is happening switch those gems up before
I gave them the Scully and then I won
today so while you nerds are always
arguing about who the only two-time
Champion is me I just became the first
three time Champion I bet you're all
wondering how I pulled it off not really
but I guess that's the tradition the key
to the whole plan was that I never
really retired or moved to Brazil I've
been living in the beaver trap this
whole time okay but what was the rest of
the plant oh we had not come up with
this but then bill came by and offered
to sell me the tube for 40 bucks and I
won pretty good stuff now Crown me this
stinks okay Michael Hitchcock you are an
amazing human slash genius and the grand
champion of the nine nine
why is your head so sweaty well because
that's actually butt skin from a botched
hair transplant so they're more pores I
can't believe this is how it ends with
Hitchcock's sweaty butt head I told
myself I wouldn't cry